STUDENT: All right.
STUDENT: Yup.
Here we go.
STUDENT: OK.
You're going to play?
STUDENT: Yeah.
I'm going to try.
[LAUGHTER]
STUDENT: OK.
STUDENT: Whoa.
Whoa.
Oh.
STUDENT: So this is our game.
[AUDIENCE OOHING AND AWING]
STUDENT: Gonna over time.
STUDENT: Yeah.
OK.
So we had a lot of stages
of development in this game,
just because we changed
our plans about 10 times.
At first, I created this really
cool mountain texture that--
so yeah.
This mountain texture.
But then we had to trouble with
it being diagonally oriented,
so we had to restart.
What was kind of
interesting about this
is that we have
the trees actually
angled so that it looks
like you're going downhill.
But really, you're on
a flat surface, which
makes it a lot easier to code.
[LAUGHTER]
We already talked a little
bit about the structure
for the trees.
Automatically, what
it sets it to is
it goes around the entire
tree, including the branches.
And so the big castle
is like basically
would occupy the entire forest,
so we had to manually narrow it
down onto trees.
In the future, we
would like to have--
in the other version that we
had to scrap, there were coins.
So you could-- they
were spinning kind of
like the rollable coins.
And you could traverse
and try and collect them.
In the future, we'd like to have
an actual person, instead of
the cube.
[LAUGHTER]
STUDENT: Budget cuts.
We can't risk real lives
on a mountain like this.
STUDENT: No.
Yeah.
It was really big.
I don't know if how
many of your games
dealt with the terraforming
feature in Unity,
but it's so cool.
You can mingle these mountains
to the right in 10 seconds.
It's super easy.
And it's very, very fun.
STUDENT: I want to see if I
can hit that invisible wall.
Yeah.
So there's this invisible
wall that keeps you
in the playing field on the
right side, which, I guess,
is kind of cheating, because
we didn't put trees there.
But--
[LAUGHTER]
STUDENT: Well.
Oh!
There's a tree.
[LAUGHTER]